-The Republicans are
at each other's throats
after a small group
of hardliners
ousted former House Speaker
Kevin McCarthy.
And now, just to add
some more kindling to the fire,
Donald Trump is
reportedly considering
flying to the Capitol
next week,
where he might even
pitch himself
as a candidate for Speaker.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Donald Trump, the far
and away frontrunner
for the Republican nomination
for president in 2024,
has spent most of the week
in a Manhattan courthouse
on trial for fraud.
In fact, he claimed
he couldn't leave,
even though he was not
required to be there.
-The corrupt attorney
general sued me for fraud,
and then they found out
they had no case,
and they have no case.
And today, if you read
the New York Law Journal,
they basically say they have
no case against Trump.
But I'm here, stuck here,
and I can't campaign.
I'd rather be right now in Iowa.
I'd rather be in New Hampshire,
in South Carolina or Ohio
or a lot of other places,
but I'm stuck here.
-He sounds like every single
married couple during lockdown.
I'd rather be in Iowa,
New Hampshire,
South Carolina or Ohio
right here.
But I'm stuck here.
So let me just sit here
and drink
this entire bottle of merlot
while I watch "Tiger King"
for the third time.
Again, not even true.
He was not stuck there.
He wasn't even required
to be there.
And yesterday he left
and flew back to Florida.
He chose to show up
so he could say
ridiculous bull[bleep],
like when he claimed
the judge in the case
undervalued his
Florida residence, Mar-a-Lago.
-He's been given
this information.
It's now been proven
to be false,
such as Mar-a-Lago
in Palm Beach, Florida,
being worth $18 million
when in fact
it's much closer
to $1.5 billion.
-No one believes your
chintzy Florida swamp hotel
is worth more than the global
box office for "Barbie."
Your [bleep] Barbie
nightmare house.
This place?
The hotel that looks like
the [bleep] castle
you put in a goldfish bowl
so he has something
to look at while he eats?
This thing looks like
the first house you buy
when you get drafted
by the Miami Heat.
Remember that photo
from the federal indictment
on all those boxes of classified
documents in his bathroom?
That doesn't look like
$1 billion property.
That looks like something
you'd see on "Hoarders."
"Oh, God.
Oh, it stinks in here."
"Well, the toilet doesn't flush,
so I've been using the boxes.
[ Laughter ]
Don't open them up.
It's classified."
So the GOP --
[ Laughs ]
So the GOP's frontrunner
for president
is facing four indictments
and a fraud trial,
probably going to get
kicked off Zillow.
And on top of that,
they currently don't even have
a Speaker of the House.
They ousted Kevin McCarthy and
then basically went on vacation.
The interim speaker,
a guy named Patrick McHenry,
a McCarthy ally,
gaveled the House into recess.
And as you can see,
he was super pissed about it.
-The chair declares
the house in recess,
subject to the call
of the chair.
[Slams gavel]
[ Laughter ]
-You do not expect that energy
from a bow tie guy?
[ Laughter ]
It's like a dad trying to get
the last piece
of Ikea furniture to fit.
God damn it!
The clergue
won't fit into the corset!
So they adjourn the House,
and the reason they did
that apparently was
that tensions were so high
over the vote to oust McCarthy,
they were genuinely afraid
there would be physical fighting
if they didn't get the hell
out of there.
-Do you agree with
Congressman McHenry's decision?
He's the temporary speaker,
The speaker pro temp,
to put a pause on the week
to let tensions settle?
-Jake, I'll be really candid.
I think if we had
stayed together
in the meeting last night,
I think that you would
have seen fists thrown.
And I'm not being dramatic
when I say that.
There is a lot of raw emotions
right now.
I think it was best
to let folks go back home,
decompress a little bit
and then come back together.
-A week? Only a week?
If someone at work did this
in the middle of a meeting,
I'd say I think we need
to take five...months.
I'll see you guys in March.
Remember, this is the same
GOP caucus that already had
a near fistfight
on the floor of the House
the first time they had to pick
a Speaker back in January.
You may recall that it took
15 votes last time
to elect McCarthy with the same
group of hardliners
holding out
and demanding concessions.
And as it dragged on,
things got so bad,
members of Congress
were lunging at each other,
including one that had to be
held back by his face.
It's one thing to be held back
by your arms or shoulders,
but your face?
That's not how you hold back
a congressman.
That's how you grab a cat that's
about to barf on a white rug.
[ Laughter ]
I really doubt a week is enough
time for everyone to chill out
because they seem really mad.
The same guy you just saw there,
Garret Graves,
was on the House floor
Tuesday yelling about
the fact that his colleague,
Matt Gaetz,
who instigated the push
to bring down McCarthy,
was fundraising
off the whole thing.
-I keep wondering
what is going on?
Are we redefining
what conservative is?
What's going on
in this country today?
What's going on in this body?
And all of a sudden my phone
keeps sending text messages.
Text messages saying,
"Hey, give me money."
Oh, look at that.
Oh, look, "Give me money.
I filed a motion to vacate."
Using official actions,
official actions to raise money.
It's disgusting.
It's what's disgusting
about Washington.
-Even worse,
during his speech,
he got this text message.
[ Laughter ]
And Graves isn't the only one
upset throwing a mini tantrum
over the GOP mega tantrum.
In fact, the GOP infighting
has gotten so intense
and so personal
that Republicans are starting
to make salacious allegations
about each other
on television.
For example, here's a GOP
senator named Markwayne Mullin
talking about Matt Gaetz's
alleged gross behavior on CNN.
-You got to think
about this guy.
This is a guy
that didn't have --
the media didn't give
a time of day to after
he was accused of sleeping
with an underage girl.
And there's a reason why no one
in the conference came
and defended him because we had
all seen the videos
he was showing
on the House floor
that all of us had walked away
of the girls
that he had slept with.
He bragged about
how he would crush ED medicine
and chase it with
with an energy drink
so he could go all night.
-Not only does Matt Gaetz
definitely look
like the spokesman
for an ED-medicine-infused
energy drink,
his name even has a Z
that you know is on the can.
[ Laughter ]
So he took ED meds and chased it
with an energy drink.
That sounds like something
Rudy Giuliani
would do by accident.
"Boss, these Tic-Tacs
don't taste very minty.
Uh-oh.
Everyone give me
three inches of space."
[ Laughter ]
But here's the especially
infuriating thing.
When this small band
of GOP hardliners voted
to oust McCarthy,
McCarthy could have,
if he really wanted
to keep his job,
reached out to Democrats
to try to win their support.
You know, the same way
he made concessions
to the hardliners
in his own caucus to get the job
in the first place.
He didn't do that.
He dissed Democrats.
He told them to "F" off.
So Democrats
voted against McCarthy
for extremely obvious reasons.
And yet Republicans
have the gall to blame Democrats
for not voting for McCarthy
and bailing them out.
-I think today
was a political decision
by the Democrats.
-Democrats just removed
the Republican Speaker.
-Democrats basically
turned on Republicans
and ousted Kevin McCarthy.
-Every one of the Democrats
voted against McCarthy.
-You had eight,
eight Republicans
that came together
yesterday with 208 Democrats.
So effectively,
this was a Democrat eviction
of Speaker McCarthy.
-Are you out of your
[bleep] minds?
Democrats are in the minority.
You constantly on [bleep] them.
Most of you claim
they stole the election,
but now you want them
to bail you out
while you accuse each other
downing Viagra like Pez
and threaten to beat
the [bleep] out of each other?
Here's a thought exercise.
Let's imagine a world where
the shoe was on the other foot
and eight Democrats
were threatening
to oust Nancy Pelosi.
You think Republicans would come
galloping in to vote for her
and keep her as Speaker
for the good of the country?
In order to think that,
you'd have to be high on ED meds
and Red Bull and ready
to bang harder than this guy.
And as if the GOP conference
couldn't become
any more of a cluster [bleep],
some Republicans are floating
the possibility
of making Trump the Speaker,
since technically it doesn't
have to be a member of Congress.
And when he was asked
about it this week,
he just didn't dismiss
it out of hand.
-Would you take the job?
Would you take the job?
-Yes, tensions are high and
Republicans are near fisticuffs.
So naturally, the person
to help calm things
down is Donald Trump.
That's like trying to soothe
a wild stallion with...
-ED medicine.
0The Republican Party
is such a mess.
They're asking for help from
a guy who's in court for fraud
because no one else
is willing to help them out.
The GOP is like a guy
who's so desperate
for a ride to the airport
he calls a friend
who's under house arrest.
-:Yeah, sure,
I can give you a ride,
but when my ankle bracelet
goes off, you've got to run!"
And now it's being reported
that Trump is planning
to fly to DC next week
for the Speaker election
to help figure things out,
which I am sure
will go smoothly.
-Now to some breaking news.
We just got this.
Donald Trump may be about
to wade
right into the middle
of the fight
over the next Speaker
of the House.
Let me tell you a little bit
about what we know.
This is being considered
by Trump.
He has not been back
to the Capitol
since before January 6th,
but he's thinking
about coming, apparently,
maybe he thinks
that he can somehow help
unify the party at this time.
-Is it really a smart idea
to go back to the Capitol
after what Trump did
on January 6th?
I mean, I'm no legal expert,
but he's been indicted.
I'm not sure
you're supposed to go back
to the scene of the crime.
He's like a guy who gets
busted on "To Catch a Predator"
then goes to the same house
a second time.
"Whoa, Chris Hansen again?!
What are the odds, man?"
"What do you have in the bag?"
"Same thing as last time."
Mike's hard lemonade
and Twizzlers.
But apparently Trump might not
just be going back to help.
He might be going to
take the job himself.
Politico reported today
that Trump is open
to pitching himself
as a speaker candidate,
according to
a Republican familiar
with internal discussions.
You know what?
Good.
Let Trump have a job
that sucks where half the people
in the room
hate his guts
and he can't do [bleep].
He'll be miserable by day two.
It's all boring procedure
and filing legislation
and saying mind-numbing
[bleep] like the gentleman
from South Carolina
is recognized.
He would hate it so much he'll
actually want to go to prison.
"Screw it.
I'm pleading guilty.
I got to get
the hell out of here.
I hate C-SPAN."
The GOP frontrunner
for president
is facing four indictments
in a fraud trial.
They don't have a speaker,
and they're threatening
to physically fight each other.
Now Trump is thinking
of flying in
to make things
even more insane.
The only way I'm going
to be able to keep up
with all this news
is if I...
-Crush ED medicine and chase it
with -- with an energy drink.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪